it is opening weekend for fifty Shades
of Grey the book that has sold over a
hundred million copies and has audience
members on their knees begging for more
of Christian and Anastasia's really
problematic relationship and I'm here
and I want to know what audience members
think about
aha there we are and thus concludes the
ABCs of BDSM what a pleasant surprise
were still here stalker
yeah he shows up uninvited all over the
place he does the same thing that Batman
does like he shows up on announce hear
that oh you're right but he doesn't
actually save people he just wants to
get that I'm gonna read you the
definition of a stalker the stalker is a
person who stealthily hunts or pursues
an animal or another person do you think
mr. graves oh yeah okay we're gonna go
do you think Anna's into it I think
she's confused because he's really hot
and really rich and if it's a neveress
joke we'd say what a stop whatever
choice you if you were a garbage
collector mr. grey would not be nearly
as seductive always play romantic or
creepy okay imagine a guy you just met
shows up at your work and you've never
told them where you work and he just
shows up unannounced
a guy that you just met says that you
can't talk to your best friend there
happens to be a guy
a guy you just met shows up to a bar
where you are drunk and drive you back
to his house depends on the guy a guy
you just met says that you can't go
visit your mom or that you shouldn't go
visit your mom you should spend time
with him I don't do romance it's all
about blindfolds okay keep it I'll wear
the flame why am I here Christian you're
here because I'm incapable leaving you
alone Judy this movie's problematic uh I
hope not there is a lot of controversy
around that line between pleasure and
pain
that relates to human relationships oh
whoa you go in deep what a piece of
advice would you give to Anna last
advice do what's right don't do what men
tell you to do ah
BDSM bondage and discipline domination
and Submission sadism and masochism a
kind of sex many read Fifty Shades of
Grey's fourth-grade prose to find out
about